no no cures I want an EKG bun definite
article ah good evening folks
today I want to talk about studying
Japanese and the most useful materials
for learning Japanese obviously I
haven't used all the different materials
in the world for studying Japanese but I
have used some and I'm familiar with
others to some extent so I'll tell you
about what I think and my experience one
of the good things about studying
Japanese is that there is such a wide
range of good materials there's just
there's a lot out there to choose from
so you can go to the bookstore and look
through a bunch of books and see which
ones appeal to you it comes down to
learning style and taste to some extent
but I'll just get into it the first
series that I used was called Japanese
for busy people so there are the title
is always kind of funny I don't know why
it's for busy people why not for
businesspeople the content of this
series is basically for business it's
for simple business situations where
like you go on a business trip to Tokyo
and you talk to like what was it mr.
Tanaka from Tokyo Electric and that kind
of thing so the situations are kind of
business I found that aspect of it a
little boring because I was never
working in business in Japan I came here
as a teacher so that it might not be
relevant for you in terms of content
completely but it's a good series and if
you go through volumes one two and maybe
three you'll learn quite a bit it's
quite well laid out it has like a short
conversation in each chapter then it
introduces the vocabulary and some
grammar from from that conversation and
gives you some exercises to practice it
and it's quite quite good useful
standard Japanese and I think it's a
good series there's another popular
series called it's called Minden no
nihongo or Japanese for everyone and
that one is quite good as well I haven't
used the whole thing but I've looked
through it and it looks quite good and a
lot of people swear by it so that's
another one to think about is mean not
only hongo or Japanese for everyone as
its called
another series I used was one that's
only published in Vancouver published at
a Japanese language school in Vancouver
I think it's called Nakagawa Language
Center and it's called gum bhakti that's
the name of the series that one was
really good was really fun it was really
motivating I really like that the best
as a pure beginners textbook there are
five volumes five volumes number one is
really simple but it goes up to five and
if you finish up to Volume five that
prepares you for the first level of the
Japanese proficiency test but all the
conversations and the characters and
stuff were quite cute and then quite
motivating they got me interested in
learning Japanese more let me just
double check the name of that Center no
not nakagawa sart's Ninagawa Japanese
Language Center so it's hard to get
those books I don't know if you can find
the Ninagawa gambatte day series but if
you can find it online I think you can
order it through the website of Ninagawa
com so have a look if you can get it
it's good for beginners at least the
lower levels so those were the beginning
textbooks at an intermediate level I
loved this book this one an integrated
approach to intermediate Japanese by
Ikeda muta and now me Honoka McGloin
this one was awesome this made me really
love studying Japanese the way it was
laid out the conversations were fun and
interesting the stories and texts were
interesting and it wasn't focused on
business it was focused on college life
and I wasn't a student but I had been a
student so I could relate to college
life a little bit better than corporate
life so the vocab and the topics and the
whole theme of this book was more
interesting to me some people don't seem
to like it I've read some of the reviews
on Amazon and some people say they find
it hard to follow it might depend on
your learning style like I'm a very
inductive learner I like to look at
texts and conversations to kind of
figure out what's going on and look at
the pieces and go ah this piece must be
the verb this must be the whatever I
like to figure things out and that works
well with this book because the
beginning of each chapter and it will
have like like two or three different
conversations or texts so if you look at
this one let's go one conversation and
it's
got another one then it's got another
one and then after that it's got a text
and then after that it has the
vocabulary and after the vocabulary then
it has that's the kanji then after that
it has the grammar points and then it
has a grammar exercises so the the texts
and the conversations are separate from
all of the the breakdown and the
explanation and the exercises those come
after the texts so for me that's fine I
like to look at the texts and the
conversations and then flip back to the
explanations when I need it and then I
can figure out the other things on my
own to whatever extent I can then I can
just flip back if I need an explanation
some people like to have the explanation
right up front in their face from the
beginning they're more deductive
learners they like to have it explained
to them before they read the text or at
the same time so if you are like that
you might not like this book that much
but have a look at it I really liked it
and this was my favorite book ever so
another one at the intermediate level
was this one which I didn't like I
didn't have as much fun with it but it
was useful it taught me a lot it's this
one
chook you kahramana bow Nyong'o that
means japanese from the intermediate
level that's the name that's the meaning
of this title but this one is completely
in Japanese this other one an integrated
approach the one I showed you before
this has a lot of English in it and has
translations and explanations this one
is all in Japanese so this one is a bit
more intense of an experience because
you have to dive right in it's all
Japanese no explanations doesn't even
have a title in English when I looked
this up on Amazon to check if it's
available I I had to type in the ISBN
number because when I typed in the
Japanese it didn't show up because it
was amazon.com in America but if I
looked up the ISBN then this name this
title appeared in Roman characters in
Amazon so it doesn't even have an
English name you would have to look up
maybe I'll put the ISBN on the screen so
you can look it up if you want but this
one's good
it's it has great texts the texts are
interesting stories and and there's a
lot of stories and there's there are
some explanations
of Proverbs and different expressions in
Japanese I found it really useful to
just go through the stories and
highlight vocabulary I didn't know and
then look at the vocabulary lists and
the grammar exercises after after the
stories I found it a bit hard to do all
of the exercises without a classroom
teacher I did this on my own at home
I've actually never taken a Japanese
lesson in my life I did it all through
self-study I found it a bit hard to do
this all at home self-study style but I
got through it and it was a bit of hard
work but I learned a lot from it so this
one is good good material just if you
have a teacher will be easier for you
because they can help you out with with
the exercises when the explanation in
Japanese is not quite clear alright so
that was intermediate level at a more
advanced level I used this one jus Q
collage oq' and Onyango
so that's Japanese from the intermediate
level to the advanced level that's what
that title means or as they say
progressing from intermediate to
advanced that's that's the way they
translated it so this one was pretty
good it was kind of a bridge between
intermediate to advanced I got about
halfway through this book and it was
good it was useful I learned a lot from
it but I started using authentic
materials instead I started just using
newspapers and and texts from magazines
and just trying to work through those
and learn vocabulary but this is good
it's similar to the to the integrated
approach to intermediate Japanese won't
like it has texts that are interesting
and then it breaks it down with the
vocab and the grammar exercises
afterwards I found it quite similar in
format and just interesting to use but
at that level I just thought it's better
to get into the authentic materials okay
so those the ones that I have used and I
think are pretty good and I recommend
I've used some others here and there and
I used some different ones for kanji
which I'll probably talk about in a
different video because kanji is a
different beast entirely and deserves
its own attention but I recommend all
those especially this one which was my
favorite integrated approach to
intermediate Japanese but if
beginner then you could get me not only
Hongo or you could get Japanese for busy
people and work through it one more note
on Japanese for busy people get the kana
version don't get the romanized version
there are two the romanized means it's
written in well has Roman characters in
it and I think it has the Japanese as
well but I don't recommend using the
romanized version because you might use
the Roman letters as a crutch it's good
to get used to the kana letters right
away from the beginning just dive right
in you can learn them very quickly if
you dive in and make yourself do it so
make yourself do it alright hope that's
helpful have a nice night guys
see ya